plaisir à première vue c'est tout ce
qu'il ya de plus simple taper sur un
clavier d'ordinateur mais pourrait même
derbali c'est une immense victoire qui
ouvre un nouveau chapitre
c'est ma vie qu'il ma deuxième vie qui
commence mais
c'est une reconnaissance un petit peu
pour moi mm derbali a reçu cette balle
lors de l'attentât la grande mosquée de
québec dont une killer rendu
tétraplégique après des mois de coma
artificiel et de soins intensifs
il a passé plus d'un an dans un centre
de réadaptation physique
tout était à reconstruire son corps sa
tête sa vie à l'époque il craignait même
de devenir un fardeau pour sa famille
vous avez vraiment un portrait plus
sombre maintenance et je reprends des
activités je peux sortir je peux je peux
faire des choses je m'occupe de tout ce
qui est des travaux dans la maison les
factures et au sol puis le steeple
d'éleveurs mon fils aymon parvient aussi
à utiliser l'écran tactile de son
cellulaire avec des outils de
reconnaissance vocale il peut espérer un
retour au travail comme consultant en
technologies de l'information
d'ailleurs il a tenté sa chance pour un
emploi il y a quelques semaines surtout
au niveau capacités cognitives en fait
j'ai pas eu de pertes au niveau de la
mémoire ou donc c'est ce qui est le plus
important
depuis le mois d'août dernier et man vit
dans une maison adaptée avec sa famille
maisons unifamiliales avec des portes et
des couloirs plus larges qui lui
permettent de circuler librement depuis
le retour chez moi je me sens très bien
surtout sur le plan aussi psychologique
de me retrouver
pourtant avec la famille donc les
enfants les enfants
cette maison c'est aussi le fruit de la
solidarité
l'an dernier des milliers de citoyens
ont participé à une campagne de sociaux
financement en ligne
résultat un chèque de 400 mille dollars
sans lequel elles mènent n'aurait jamais
pu acheter ce logis le mal et était très
minime très minime dans dans cette vie
en fait surtout qui est plus important
c'est beaucoup beaucoup de bien
ému par tout ce soutien est maintenant
qu'une envie donner au suivant a sa
propre façon maintenant qu'il a lui même
fait la paix avec tout ce qu'il a
traversé ici alexandre duval radio
canada québec